You've seen this happen, right?
You see 2 events that look
almost exactly the same, but the
way they're talked about in the
news totally different.
How does that work?
Well, today we're going to
unpacked exactly that.
How media framing can spend 2
completely different stories
from the same set of actions and
why that really, really matters.
To get to the bottom of this,
we've got to look at a key idea
from political strategist Frank
Luntz.
He famously said it's not what
you say, it's what people hear.
And that's it right there.
It's not just about the words,
it's about the picture those
words paint inside your head.
That simple idea is the key to
everything we're about to
explore.
So here's the puzzle we're
trying to solve.
What's going on when the actions
on the ground are basically the
same, You know, clearing out
city streets, but the stories
were told about those actions
are polar opposites?
How are we, the public, supposed
to figure out what's actually
happening?
OK, so the tool we need here is
a concept called framing.
This is what's going to help us
pull apart the operational
reality.
That's what's literally
happening on the street from the
political narrative, which is
the story that's being told
about it.
So what exactly is framing?
Look, it isn't necessarily about
lying.
It's more about choosing what to
highlight, which words you use,
which images you show.
It's like putting a filter on a
camera.
It's the lens you're being shown
the world through.
And that lens can change abs
absolutely everything.
All right, let's dive into our
first case study.
We're going to call this one a
simple broom.
We're in San Francisco, November
2023.
This is our baseline, a really
clear example of what happened
versus what was said about it.
The facts on the ground were
pretty straightforward.
San Francisco was about to host
some of the most powerful people
in the world for the APEC
summit.
So they launched this huge
citywide cleanup.
Homeless camps were cleared.
Graffiti got scrubbed away.
Sidewalks were power washed.
The action was obvious, and so
was the reason for it.
And here's the thing.
The way they talked about it was
just as direct.
California's Governor Gavin
Newsom didn't try to spin it as
some big permanent fix.
No, he basically said we're just
cleaning the house before
company comes over.
He was completely open about it
being for the summit.
The story matched the action,
and that's the key right there.
The public description lined up
with the reality.
It was a temporary cosmetic
sweep for a very specific event.
The action, the broom was
allowed to be just a broom, no
more, no less.
OK, so that's case one.
Pretty straightforward right?
Now let's pivot to our second
case.
And this is where things get,
well, a lot more complicated.
We're going to look at a
hypothetical situation for
Washington, DC in 2025, one
based on stated political plans.
The actions might look familiar,
but the story, it becomes a
loaded weapon.
So here's how it would go down,
step by step.
First, the DC police force gets
put under federal control.
Then the National Guard is
deployed onto the streets, and
finally, a broken window
strategy gets rolled out.
They start cracking down on
small time offenses and just
like in San Francisco,
dismantling homeless camps.
The playbook is almost
identical, but the story told
about it?
Whoa.
It's not one story, it's two,
and they are completely at war
with each other.
On one side, it's framed as a
righteous war on crime, a
mission to take back the
capital, and on the other, it's
an authoritarian federal coup,
basically a military takeover of
an American city.
The broom is definitely not just
a broom anymore.
But hang on a second.
There's a piece of data here
that throws a real wrench in
that war on Crime Story.
In the year right before this
hypothetical crackdown, official
data showed that violent crime
in DC was already down by 26%.
That fact makes you stop and
ask, wait, if crime is already
dropping, what is this war
really about?
So what is going on here?
How do we make sense of this
massive difference?
It really all comes down to what
you could call an asymmetry of
honesty.
The way the story was told in
each case was just fundamentally
different.
Let's just put them side by
side.
It makes it super clear.
The action a cosmetic cleanup
versus a federalized crackdown.
Pretty similar on the ground,
but the stated motive 1 is
cleaning for guests, the other
is taking back the capital.
And that difference in motive is
what causes the media frame to
split right down the middle from
a simple cosmetic sweep into
this huge battle between war on
crime and authoritarian coup.
Now, to be really clear, this
isn't about saying both events
are morally the same.
That's not the point.
The real issue here, the
analytical problem, is that in
that second case, the public
isn't even given the option of a
simple, factual story.
We're only offered two
competing, highly politicized
narratives about what happened.
OK, so why should you care about
any of this?
Because learning to see past the
story, learning to spot the
frame, honestly, that's like a
superpower for navigating the
world today.
Think about it.
The frame changes the movie that
plays in your head.
War on crime makes you picture
SWAT teams and raids.
Cleaning for a visitor makes you
picture, well, St. sweepers.
The skill you have to build is
to always separate the two.
What is the operational reality
on the ground and what is the
political narrative they're
trying to lay on top of it?
So I'll leave you with this.
It's a simple question you can
use every single day.
The next time you see a big news
story, a political announcement,
anything, just stop and ask
yourself, am I seeing the broom
or am I just seeing the story
about the broom?
Trust me, the answer can tell
you everything you need to know.